You better get ready to use that pause button
because you don’t want to miss any of these
hidden Easter Eggs. These Disney moments move
by so fast that if you don’t pause the screen
you will never notice them but don’t you
worry. We’ve got you covered and we will
show you some of the hardest to find moments
in your favorite Disney films. Don’t forget
to subscribe and join the notification squad
to get up to date content daily.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Paused
Disney Moments That Reveal Hidden Easter Eggs.
Monsters, Inc.
When the scarers go in and out of doors to
scare little children pay close attention
to the items on the doors. Like most children,
the kids in Monsters, Inc. place stickers
on the outside of their doors and if you look
closely you’ll notice something special
about these stickers. They are the little
critter characters from the Woody’s Round-Up
TV show in Toy Story 2. It looks like Woody
is still popular during the time of Monsters,
Inc. maybe that’s why Jesse shows up in
Boo’s room.
Inside Out
Inside Out has several Easter Eggs and we
have mentioned quite a few of them in past
videos but one arrives in the beginning of
the film that if you were still getting popcorn
you might have missed it. When the Anderson
family is driving to their new home they drive
past a field of corn but look at the telephone
wires. Sitting on the wires are the birds
from the Pixar short, For the Birds. The cool
part is, For the Birds must have taken place
in the fall when the corn is dried up and
Inside Out during the spring as it grows.
It looks like no one headed south for the
winter.
Cars 2
The Pizza Planet truck is a popular Easter
egg to spot and in Cars 2 he shows up during
the casual race as a spectator. This one isn’t
so hard to spot but many people don’t realize
he’s in two scenes in this film. When Guido
is showing off his drink mixing skills stop
looking at him and look above him to the TV.
The Pizza Planet truck is being interviewed,
maybe that’s why he’s in so many Pixar
films, he’s a world famous celebrity!
Toy Story
The first Toy Story film is what started it
all for Disney, Pixar and rightly so, this
film still holds up today and will for another
bazillion years. We’re pretty sure no one
will argue with us on that point but one argument
that stands the test of time is Star Trek
versus Star Wars. The people at Pixar couldn’t
make a choice in 1995’s Toy Story. Check
out Buzz’s hand when he says goodbye, Spock
would be proud and when Buzz talks about Emperor
Zurg’s evil plan. He speaks directly about
the Death Star
even in part two we find out Buzz is the son
of Zurg. Sound familiar?
Finding Dory
In Finding Nemo we learned that the dentist
not only likes to cause pain to the children
he works on but he also likes to provide his
niece with fish, no matter how many she kills.
She shouldn’t own fish and it seems like
the people at the Marine Life Institute know
she shouldn’t too. In Finding Dory they
have her picture up on the wall at the institute.
Or maybe it’s hanging there because she
belongs in the quarantine section because
something is wrong with her.
Cars
George Carlin is highly regarded as one of
the greatest and most influential stand-up
comedians of all time. Despite a great career
in stand-up he also provided the voice of
the character Fillmore in 2006’s Cars. The
characters in this film are usually moving
and we never get too close to the license
plates but many of the license plates have
double means. For instance Fillmore’s license
plate reads 51237, which stands for Carlin’s
birthdate, May 12th 1937.
A Bug’s Life
Here is one that you have to pause two different
films and have a pretty good eye. In the film
A Bug’s Life the ants live under a fancy
looking tree that seems to mean more than
meets the eye. If you watch Toy Story 2 you
will notice that the film has the same exact
tree in it. Just look at that shape! With
the erosion around the tree in A Bug’s Life
we have to wonder what event took place to
cause that erosion and will that be the subject
of an upcoming Pixar film?
The Black Cauldron
In the 1980’s Disney was looking at the
success of Jim Henson’s 1982 film The Dark
Crystal for inspiration. They saw that dark,
fantasy adventure films were on the rise and
they wanted to get into that market. That’s
why they released The Black Cauldron in 1985;
but they also pulled inspiration from their
1953 film Peter Pan. When Taran heads into
a cave, he is surrounded by fairies and one
is none other than the attitude filled, Tinkerbell.
Remember to only think happy thoughts.
Zootopia
Zootopia has numerous references to pop culture
that they even hired Shakira to portray Gazelle.
Judy Hopps even has a portable music player
with music from Fur Fighters, Fleetwood Yak,
and The Beagles but we only caught one from
Star Wars. When the stars of Zootopia break
into Cliffside they look around with a flashlight.
Pause the video and you will see the code
TK-421 on the wall, as any good Star Wars
fan knows, this is reference to a foolish
Stormtrooper that fell for the oldest trick
in the book.
The Incredibles
When Elastigirl flies a plane, she identifies
her plane to the radio tower. It stands for
I G 99, which also stands for the Iron Giant
that was released in 1999 by director, Brad
Bird. Then when she is in the control tower,
A113 makes an appearance too. A113 refers
to a classroom number at the California Institute
of Arts, where many artists from Disney started
their careers including Brad Bird. Looks like
Bird likes to reference his past.
There you have it ten ten Paused Disney Moments
That Reveal Hidden Easter Eggs. Don’t forget
to subscribe to Screen Rant for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching.